okay hello
everyone once again i'm smiling studying
molecular biology and genetics at
bachelor university in turkey
i'm working as an undergraduate research
assistant in a cancer biology laboratory
and until now i studied non-small cell
lung carcinoma and pancreatic cancer
in the wet lab focusing on cell cycle
emt mechanism and metastasis
and also chronic neophysitic leukemia
and dried up with
experience with pine biotech actually my
knowledge of bioinformatics and
computational biology was very limited
and that's why i wanted to improve
myself in this field because
as you know as a scientist we need to be
able to see the big picture as much as
the small details
so in order to do this we should have
the knowledge of the big data science
and need to learn how to process and
analyze
high throughput data so while i was
looking for an opportunity to gain
experience
and knowledge i came across the pine
biotech fellowship program
and enrolled as an intern for three
months
during this period i took several online
courses about
omix technologies and machine learning
which was a great environment to learn
and practice with hands-on assignments
moreover there were several quizzes for
each course in order to evaluate
ourselves and repeat the information
so i can say that courses were very
helpful for me because it was starting
with the basic information
and continuing by increasing the
complexity
also i had the opportunity to
participate in webinars like this one
and these were very beneficial because
it was increasing my curiosity for the
upcoming details
so one of the best sides of this program
was to have weekly meetings with our
mentors and other participants
each week we were sharing our progress
asking our questions and discussing them
together
it was a really positive environment to
learn and discuss the topics
additionally when i needed anything
anytime i could be able to contact and
go
and get a guidance from my advisors
immediately without waiting
uh for the weekly meetings furthermore
there were two huge opportunities that i
can benefit from
and the first one is the tea bioinfo
server which is the platform that we are
using for processing and analyzing the
data
and it's very user friendly that even
with a little knowledge you can learn
and practice with it step by step
and the second one is the quadomix logic
platform actually coding was very hard
and
complex for me but this platform
explains and shows the coding with very
basic steps so
even though i had some difficulties it
it made coding more enjoyable for me
so my favorite part of this program
was to have an individual project which
was the place to show
our knowledge and the practices so like
the theory needed to become practical
it was a great opportunity to come up
with a hypothesis
and develop the answers over time so
nearly
within two months i completed a project
titled identification of lincrnas as
therapeutic targets in
chronic lymphocytic leukemia so my main
goal was to identify possible
therapeutic targets
in order to be able to trigger the
spontaneous regression mechanism
which is the disappearance of the tumor
over time
with or without any treatment in
different cancer types
for this i use an rna-seq data set from
a bioproject
that can be found in cbi basically with
the help of the tibial infraserver
i conducted transcriptomics analysis by
comparing spontaneous
regression and the progressive state of
chronic lymphocytic leukemia
i determined differentially expressed
genes among two groups
by differential gene expression analysis
and identified significant genes
through statistical analysis
consequently significant protein coding
genes were correlated with rna-related
pathways
therefore i investigated the non-coding
genes and found
highly expressed 33 link rnas
with further analysis i identified three
significant
incarnates that can be important in
regression mechanism
and can be used as therapeutic targets
but of course if these findings are
confirmed by additional studies we can
say that
these found link rnas can be used as
therapeutic targets
so my research revealed new perspectives
regarding spontaneous regression in its
association with link rnas
in final words this research fellowship
program
enabled me to master the field of
bioinformatics
more than i thought and in my new
project i definitely plan to use high
throughput data and perform
more comprehensive studies and once
again
thank you to the pine biotech team for
this wonderful environment
thank you